it's crazy I mean it's quite first time
doing a TV show and now I've got a
season two so the first year was you
know different wild in so many different
ways and now I think don't into season
two it's going to just get better and
better the show I mean how different is
it for you you know you mentioned that
it's different for you on a TV series in
what way well so for the fur in the
beginning we were doing press I didn't
have weekends for months and that's not
really good for your head because you
have to do 10 pages dialogue advice okay
but you have to promote the show and I
guess that's was like that we got to
like time this better yeah and so I
wasn't sleeping wasn't getting any time
off and then I'm used to that for maybe
four months maximum this is nine months
and it's every day and every day and
every day and you actually get we all
joke about this you kind of get punished
for doing a good job so then as soon as
you say really all we can say those
lines was given more kinetic evening
we're algorithms yeah and let's make him
say it while he's doing the action so
it's adjusted hires who's on the show he
was only working one day we half a day a
week half day in episodes like eight
days and now he's on the whole show he's
like dang it because he was so good they
yeah yeah all right so what can fans
expect from this upcoming season what
have you got I mean that's always a
tough question because I know you can't
be Daniel shot it I don't know if you
are anything have you heard about
scripts have you I have well I have and
I and I don't because I've also heard
some of them kind of being pulled so I
know that there's going to be a casino
episode okay which I'm looking forward
to doing on the original there was a
casino episode where he uses a paperclip
and string and he puts it on a woman's
dress and they like steps on it and she
walks away and it pulls her dress off
and then everyone goes on and he like
uses these dice that can get loaded by
making some contraption the bathroom so
that was an entertaining episode and I
get to dress up in a tux and sure or at
least a suit again so that was a good
day so that's good one yes so is there
anything in your life that you're like
are you handy
can you MacGyver things or are you yeah
I mean yeah don't want to brag too much
but I mean yeah the next question a
diver does not have an answer but I
don't know I mean I'm a guy verrat work
every day yes
I mean we really cuz I was spending so
much time doing voiceover I was like I
can't do this on my Sunday so let's cut
the voice-over down right so that means
that in the voice-over I'm explaining
what I'm doing yet all these algorithms
and you know now I have to do that on
camera while I'm doing the MacGyver ring
cutting up firehose and attaching
together and Shelby have a building or
did you feel that this show has made you
much more handy oh yeah yeah yeah you
can't you can't do that much and not get
at least a little bit like a muscle you
just get better and better at first it
was like 10 pages a day what am I going
to do yeah George EADS really helped me
out a lot my co-star so he and I was but
by the end I really got to hang out with
Matt I can do this no what is it that
you think that people love so much about
the show I mean there's always a little
nugget to go into something I mean the
idea of them macgyvering or doing that
is it's kind of fascinating and it's fun
yeah what do you think is is north I
think you dude what do you think because
at first I was like well the action is
gonna be great an action is great but
it's really the characters you know
George and I we work a lot at this it's
not like we go home we just come back we
stayed alive I mean we would go home and
rehearse for two hours sometimes to kind
of figure out if there was a may way
make something stuff better and and yeah
you know it's really the work that all
of us put into it everyone really does
care so it's really cool but yes the
characters and their relationships with
each other and the humors I signed on
for an action comedies there's I was
like hey guys let's get back this comedy
stuff because you know the melodrama I
know what no one wants to go and watch
at what I think in America it's 8:00 on
a Friday night no one wants to watch
something miserable holiday at 8 o'clock
on a Friday night let's watch something
fun yes yeah and we are there and drama
when it needs to be booked yeah yes most
fun I think that's what it is but also
MacGyver you know that's the coat of
paint is MacGyver's like absolutely
George and Lucas goofing off with
macgyverism
yeah what's the vibe like on set like
you must have some pretty epic bloopers
I know I just actually approve the gag
reel I like it when you must have right
yeah well George said it batches like
dude man we are crazy
yeah I know well you have to have fun
when you're working that much
I mean why would you want to be on a
miserable set so I mean I think but just
trying to get all those things and
putting them together you must have like
oh for sure right lots of injuries as
well really oh yeah who's the mother
there on the set that taking care of
every Meredith eaten the woman that
plays our boss now she is I was just
talking to the other day soon as I was
it was like talking to this mom you know
she's like takes care of and she used to
be a I don't know what the word would be
psychotherapists is like a million
saying yes and so that's our exactly